.
Geht's?
- Ja.
Kommt schon gut.
* Ruhige Klavierklänge *
(Frau) Ihr meldet euch, gell?
Ja. Sobald wir dort sind,
rufen wir an.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Am Morgen um 0.30 Uhr
hört ihr von uns.- Ist gut.
Mike, mach's gut.
Danke für alles.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Neue Heimat Florida:
Mike Hostettler
und seine Frau Marina Marrer
wollen in den USA
ein Waffelrestaurant eröffnen.
Hallo!
- Grüss dich.
Späte Liebe: Eva Dudle
und ihr Partner Philippe Sguaitamatti
planen in der Toskana ein Agriturismo
mit sechs Ferienwohnungen.
Und aus dem Aargau
an die Atlantikküste.
Bauernfamilie Wieser
will expandieren.
In Frankreich erwirbt sie einen Hof
mit über 400 Tieren und 240 ha Land.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
# Uf u dervo ...
* Muhen *
* Pfeifen *
Alles gut.
Die Tage auf dem Bauernhof in Oberhof
sind gezählt.
Komm vor.
Komm.
Sandro Wieser zieht mit seinen Tieren
nach Frankreich.
Es vergeht kein Tag bei der Arbeit,
an dem du nicht siehst,
was du gemacht hast.
* Glocken bimmeln. *
Ich glaube, so wie sie aussehen,
sind sie zufrieden.
* Muhen *
Gell, Mädel?
* Er schnalzt. *
Mädchen.
Das war unser erstes Kalb hier.
Das wird auch eine Französin.
Mein Grossvater sagte immer, dass
man keine Lieblingskuh haben darf.
Aber ich habe sie schon.
Ja, es sind zwei Seiten:
die emotionale,
wenn man so zahme Kühe hat.
Dann gibt es
sicherlich auch jene Kühe,
die gute Leistungen bringen,
gesund sind.
Hey!
Der Hof von Familie Wieser
liegt in der Nähe von Aarau.
Mehr als 50 Tiere
gehören zum Betrieb.
Und 18 ha Land.
Erst vor zehn Jahren ist die Familie
in die Landwirtschaft eingestiegen.
Jetzt steht ihr Hof
kurz vor dem Verkauf.
Aleksandra Wieser
räumt bereits das Haus.
Sie kam durch ihren Mann Sandro
zur Landwirtschaft.
Ich wuchs als Kind in der Stadt auf.
Ich bin ein Stadtkind.
High Heels, Fingernägel ...
... all das.
Aber es fehlt mir nicht.
Gummistiefel sind definitiv
viel bequemer als High Heels.
Das muss man mal gesagt haben.
Aber sie sind sehr schön
zum Anschauen.
Aleksandra ist gelernte Verkäuferin.
An das Leben als Bäuerin
musste sie sich erst gewöhnen.
Sandro
wollte schon lange auswandern.
Er wollte nach Neuseeland.
Ich sagte ganz klar,
dass ich nicht so weit weggehe.
Allein wegen
der zwei grossen Kinder.
Die Entfernung ist einfach zu gross.
Ja.
Dann ergab sich das mit dem Hof.
Mein Mann ist so,
der kann sich nicht einfach
auf den Lorbeeren ausruhen.
Er muss immer ein wenig mehr machen.
Er ging einmal mit Freunden
nach Frankreich
und schaute sich ein wenig um.
Einmal kam er nach Hause und sagte,
dass er etwas gesehen hätte.
Ich fand dann: "Ja, okay."
Und jetzt packen wir und gehen.
Schon schwer.
* Melancholische Klavierklänge *
Auswandern heisst für Aleksandra
und ihren Mann viel mehr
als nur den Wohnort zu wechseln.
Sie müssen auch einen Teil
der Familie zurücklassen.
Tochter Joana und Sohn Sascha sind
erwachsen und bleiben in der Schweiz.
Nur der achtjährige Gian
kommt mit nach Frankreich.
* Schwermütige Klavierklänge *
(Sandro) Nina, nein. Nina!
Im Berner Oberland
hat ein anderer Auswanderer
heute seinen letzten Arbeitstag.
Willst du es so oder so?
Lieber so.
- So?
Mike Hostettler bricht
in wenigen Wochen in die USA auf.
Die letzte Kundin
auf meinem Schragen.
Sehr speziell.
Tätowieren ist Mikes Leidenschaft.
Eine Passion, die er abends
und am Wochenende ausübt.
* Die Tätowiernadel surrt. *
Denn seinen Job als Polizist
wollte er nicht aufgeben.
Amerika ist seit bald 20 Jahren ...
... ein Traum.
Ich war schon früher immer
der Indianer- und Cowboyfreak.
Die Route 66
hat mich immer fasziniert.
Das ist von Jahr zu Jahr
immer mehr gewachsen.
Jetzt, mit 44, möchte Mike seinen
Traum nicht mehr länger aufschieben
und wagt den Neuanfang in Florida.
Hopp, hopp.
Mit seiner Frau Marina möchte er dort
ein Waffelrestaurant eröffnen.
Dafür sind sie bereit, ihre gesamten
Ersparnisse zu investieren.
Komm, Djuna.
Der Traum Amerika
kommt eher von Mike.
Aber für mich war
einfach schon immer klar,
dass ich nicht ewig
am gleichen Ort bleiben will.
Ich möchte Neues erleben,
neue Leute kennenlernen.
Möglichst viel erleben im Leben.
Die Schweiz ist zu klein.
Die Schweiz ist nichts
von der ganzen Welt.
Komm.
Lange fehlte Marina und Mike
die passende Geschäftsidee,
die sie zum Einwandern in die USA
brauchten.
Der Zufall brachte den Stein
schliesslich ins Rollen.
Djuni.
Ja, bei uns ist es wunderschön.
Wir haben noch ein paar Koffer,
die wir füllen müssen.
Ansonsten
haben wir wirklich alles ausgeräumt.
* Seufzer *
Sonst ist alles weg.
In Bern besuchten die beiden
ein Waffelrestaurant
einer Gastronomiekette.
Diese suchte selbstständige Partner,
sog. Franchisenehmer.
Marina und Mike bewarben sich
und so kam eines zum anderen.
Wir haben beide noch nie
in einem Restaurant gearbeitet.
Aber dadurch,
dass es ein Franchisesystem ist,
bekommt man natürlich Hilfe.
Dann müssen wir einen Kurs machen,
um in Amerika
ein Restaurant führen zu dürfen.
Da lernen wir auch viel.
So, das muss reichen.
Hey, vielen Dank.
- Ganz lieben Dank und alles Gute.
Pfleg es noch gut.
Meister.
- Schöne Zeit und guten Start.
Hast du die Richtige?
- Ja, schon.
Waffeleisen anstatt Tätowiernadel:
Ihre zukünftigen Kunden
wollen Mike und Marina
unter der heissen Sonne Floridas
empfangen.
Am liebsten duschen, Tasche packen
und ab in den Flieger.
Das war einmal. Tschüss und weg.
* Rockige Gitarrenklänge *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Im Tösstal
bereiten sich Philippe Sguaitamatti
und seine Partnerin Eva Dudle
auf einen neuen Lebensabschnitt vor.
Heute tragen sie Möbel
von unterschiedlichen Orten zusammen.
Andersherum.
Die beiden wollen nach Italien.
Ist gut!
So.
- Also. Macht jemand auf?
Super. Sagst du, wenn es oben ist?
Gut.
- Okay.
Eva ist 67.
Achtung,
ich lasse euch wieder runter.
Trotz Rentenalter arbeitet sie
noch immer als Kindergartenlehrerin.
Ist's gut?
Kannst ihn aufstellen
und hierhin stellen.
Philippe ist 65
und frisch pensioniert.
Er arbeitete
bei der Flughafenpolizei in Zürich.
Sieht sehr schön aus.
Jawohl.
Ich habe total gerne alte Sachen.
Erstens
kann man immer alles flicken.
Und zweitens hat es mehr Stil
als das Zeug,
mit dem man einmal umzieht
und es danach wegwerfen kann.
Der Schrank z.B. ist 350 Jahre alt.
Den habe ich für 370 Fr. gekauft.
Die Möbel sollen in die Toskana.
Alles gut, Schnabeltier?
Die beiden
möchten ein Agriturismo eröffnen.
Die italienische Variante
für Ferien auf dem Bauernhof.
Bevor ich Philippe kennenlernte,
hatte ich schon im Piemont gesucht.
Erstens habe ich sehr wenig Rente.
Also ich habe 2'100 Fr. AHV.
Davon lebt man in der Schweiz
nicht gut.
Das ist das eine und das Zweite ist,
dass ich einfach nicht
nichts machen kann.
Ich muss immer etwas arbeiten.
Ich muss immer etwas zu tun haben
und etwas Sinnvolles machen,
sonst bin ich unglücklich.
Eva fährt zu einem Lagerhaus.
Dort bewahren die beiden
einen Teil der Sachen auf,
die sich in ihrem bewegten Leben
angesammelt haben.
Eva hat sieben erwachsene Kinder
von drei unterschiedlichen Männern.
Ah, du bist schon dran. Sehr gut.
- Ja.
Philippe hat drei Kinder grossgezogen
und lebt seit Jahren
getrennt von seiner Frau.
All diese Möbel hier,
die blau markierten Sachen,
inklusive des grossen hier,
das dort hinten auch -
die kommen alle in die Toskana.
Achtung mit dem Ding,
das müsst ihr so nehmen, sonst ...
Die Liebe zu Italien
hat Philippe im Blut -
seine Grosseltern stammen von dort.
Und auch Eva
ist von Italien begeistert.
Wir beide haben schon lange
damit geliebäugelt.
Das Piemont ist schon gut,
aber es hat einen riesigen Nachteil:
Es ist nicht am Meer.
Deshalb haben wir uns
nach weiter unten orientiert.
Wir haben das gesucht und gefunden.
Jetzt im Moment müssen wir uns
schwer dahinterklemmen.
Aber dann soll es
etwas Gutes werden.
Drehen, ja.
Wenn du kannst, hier halten.
Bei mir ist's gut.
Das hier sind alles meine Sachen.
Und das dort sind Philippes.
Sechs Ferienwohnungen
wollen sie anbieten -
für bis zu 24 Gäste.
Willst du eigentlich
eines der Häuser
auch mit solchen Tischen ausrüsten?
- Das weiss ich noch nicht.
Im Ganzen haben wir
drei oder vier davon.
Wovon?
- Von den runden Tischen.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier ...
Zwei.
- Zwei?
Ja.
Also ...
Hast du auch noch
so einen kleinen wie ich?
Ich habe den grossen.
Aber den willst du doch
im Wohnzimmer?
Ja, eventuell, ich weiss es nicht.
Einen grossen Tisch haben wir
eingeladen.- Ja, das ist richtig.
Wir überlegen,
wie wir es dort machen.
* Gemütliche Klänge *
Noch geht in Oberhof bei Familie
Wieser alles seinen gewohnten Gang.
Andere gehen ins Fitnesscenter,
ich gehe Scheisse schippen.
* Bellen *
* Muhen *
Sandro hat von früh bis spät zu tun.
Wenn nicht in Gummistiefeln,
dann in Hemd und Sakko.
Tschau, Domenik.
Tschau, Marion.
Nebst der Landwirtschaft
ist Sandro Geschäftsführer
bei einem Finanzdienstleister.
Als Betriebsökonom gründete er
die Firma vor sieben Jahren.
Thommy, sollen wir rasch
die Netto-Abrechnungen anschauen?
Thomas Keller
ist Sandros Geschäftspartner.
Hast du sie offen?
- Das sind sie.
Das ist Ende Jahr fertig,
das habe ich so laufen lassen.
Das lasse ich auch laufen.
Schöne Bonuszahlung.
- Mhm.
Ja, ist gut.
Diese Offenbarung im Sommer er-
wischte mich auf dem falschen Fuss.
Aber Sandro ist immer wieder
für eine Überraschung gut.
Ich musste es schon verheimlichen.
Ich präsentiere keine
halbherzigen Ideen oder Pläne.
Damit macht man auf Deutsch gesagt
alle Leute verrückt.
Am Schluss klappt es nicht so,
wie man es sich vorgestellt hat.
Irgendwann
sind mir die Ausreden ausgegangen,
was ich so mache im Ausland.
Aber zum Glück ging es zügig
und ich konnte die Karten aufdecken.
Ich wurde nicht in Notlügen
oder Lügen verstrickt.
Also ich habe nicht gemerkt,
dass etwas im Busch ist.
Also habe ich es clever gemacht.
- Ja.
Seinen Posten als Geschäftsführer
wird Sandro wegen der Auswanderung
abgeben.
Die Florida-Auswanderer haben ihr
gemietetes Haus im Berner Oberland
unterdessen verlassen
und sind zu Marinas Eltern gezogen.
Heute feiert Marinas Grossmutter
Geburtstag.
Schau, Mike hat sich auf
deinem Geburtstagskuchen verewigt.
Das hat er schön gemalt.
Er musste für Amerika
noch ein wenig üben.
Ich habe nur geschrieben.
Einfach so zusammenkommen -
das wird bald nicht mehr gehen.
Wir haben viel unternommen, um
sie dazu zu bewegen, hierzubleiben.
Z.B. amerikanisches Bier geschenkt,
das man nicht trinken kann,
aber es hat alles nichts genützt.
Mittlerweile habe ich mich
an den Gedanken gewöhnt.
Ich freue mich, wenn ich rübergehen
und sie besuchen kann.
Ich hoffe, dass es gut geht,
dass ihre Pläne und Wünsche
in Erfüllung gehen
und sie erfolgreich sind.
Irgendjemand in der Familie
muss ja einen Plan haben.
Obwohl ich nie gedacht hätte,
dass sie das sein wird.
Sie war sonst immer
gegen Heirat und Kinder.
Ja ...
Mir sagte heiraten
nie wirklich viel.
Man muss nicht verheiratet sein,
damit man sich lieben
oder zusammen sein kann.
Beim Auswandern ist alles einfacher,
wenn man verheiratet ist.
Man hat gewisse Vorteile,
man ist abgesichert.
Deshalb haben wir
diesen Schritt gemacht.
Es ist ein fremdes Land,
es ist nicht grad um die Ecke.
Es geht um ein Business
und viel Geld.
Und wir sind
ein paar Jahre auseinander.
Zur Absicherung in finanzieller
Hinsicht macht das sehr wohl Sinn.
Mike ist nicht nur
15 Jahre älter als Marina,
er hat auch noch drei Kinder
aus einer früheren Beziehung.
Sie bleiben bei der Mutter
in der Schweiz.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Bevor es in Florida losgehen kann,
müssen die Auswanderer nach Berlin.
Uns erwartet eine Woche Kurs.
Lernen, wie man Waffeln macht
im Herzstück von WonderWaffel.
Ja, vorbereiten auf Florida.
Das Konzept für ihr Waffelrestaurant
übernehmen Mike und Marina
von einer Franchisefirma.
Dafür bezahlen sie monatlich
eine fixe Gebühr
an die Gründer der Gastronomiekette.
Hey, Ulvi, alles gut?
- Alles gut?- Hallo, Ulvi.
M ist für dich.
- Ja, Danke schön.
Und die andere Grösse für dich.
-Danke schön.
Alles klar, dann kommt mal mit.
Also Leute, jetzt geht's los.
Wir fangen das erste Mal an
zu arbeiten. Der Traum wird wahr.
Man kann richtig draufhauen,
das ist alles gar kein Problem.
Wenn du jetzt eine oder zwei
WonderWaffeln drin hast,
kannst du z.B.
die Banane aufschneiden,
den Riegel rausholen,
auspacken, hinstellen.
Sosse draufgeben, Früchte,
die Riegel schon aufgemacht.
Du kannst auch den Namen
schon draufschreiben. Okay?- Mhm.
Du musst gar nicht drücken.
Nicht drücken?- Nein.
Sonst hast du viel zu viel Sosse.
Jetzt muss ich die Schrift
noch ein wenig schöner machen.
Das wird
meine grösste Challenge sein.
Ich mache sehr gerne so Filigranes.
Das passt 100%ig.
Wirklich perfekt. Voll mein Ding.
In Florida wollen die Schweizer
genau solche Waffeln herstellen.
Auch mit Puder und Schokocreme?
Marina und Mike übernehmen
auch das Design des Restaurants.
Rund 45 Lokalitäten dieser Art
gibt es bereits.
In Amerika sind sie die zweiten.
Happy Birthday, alles Gute!
Geht's so?
- Ja, danke.- Guten Appetit.
Die Kunden können aus
mehreren Dutzend Zutaten auswählen.
... vier.
- Warte, Bananen ...
Jede Waffel ist anders, da darf
den beiden kein Fehler passieren.
Unsere Strategie ist,
eine nach der anderen zu machen.
(Frau) Das ist eigentlich Amira.
Das ist der falsche Name.
Ah, Scheisse,
soll ich den wegputzen?
Hm, ich frag mal, ob es okay ist.
Oder einfach die Waffel wegnehmen,
neuer Teller.
Einfach die Waffel
auf den Teller schieben. - Warum?
Falscher Name.
- Ach so.
(Frau) Genau,
einfach hier drauf packen.
(Mann) Am besten mit dem Messer.
(Frau) Genau, dann streust du
noch mal ein bisschen ...- Ja.
Super-GAU,
den falschen Namen draufgeschrieben.
Das kommt davon,
wenn es richtig läuft.
Aber weitermachen.
Hier kommt Stracciatella-Eis drauf.
Haben sie dir schon gezeigt,
wie man Eis drauf macht?- Ja.
Auch wenn es noch etwas harzt,
Mike glaubt fest an den Erfolg
ihres Vorhabens.
Waffeln kennen sie in Amerika.
Aber nicht so zubereitet wie hier
mit den verschiedenen Zutaten.
Dort gibt es die nackte Waffel,
vielleicht mit etwas Honig.
Das ist ein sehr spezielles Produkt,
das sie so noch nicht kennen, nein.
Amira?
Guten Appetit.
- Danke.
Wollen wir noch kurz zusammensitzen
bezüglich Marketing?
Ich habe noch Fragen,
wie wir vorgehen möchten bezüglich
Social Media hauptsächlich.
Thommy?
Ich bin gegangen.
Hast du noch etwas?
- Ja.
Wie könnte es auch anders sein.
In Basel hat Sandro Feierabend.
Voila!
Sag Grüsse zu Hause.
- Du auch. Danke. Tschau.
Tschau, Domenik.
Die Übernahme des Hofes in Frankreich
ist für Sandro und seine Familie
mit vielen Unsicherheiten verbunden.
Alleine muss man so was
nicht durchziehen wollen.
Nachher fühlt sich einer unwohl.
Das muss
eine gemeinsame Entscheidung sein.
Insbesondere auch
für unseren Kleinsten.
Wenn er merkt,
dass es ziemlich einstimmig ist,
ist es auch für ihn suggestiv
einfacher zum Verarbeiten
und um sich daran zu gewöhnen.
Das ist ein Zeichen.
* Verspielte Klänge *
Bin wieder hier.
Ich ziehe mich jetzt um.
In der Schweiz hat Sandro 55 Tiere.
In Frankreich
werden es über 400 sein.
Dann noch Kuh 2.
Mich nervt nichts an der Schweiz.
So wie ich wirtschaften will,
ist es in der Schweiz
nicht mehr gefragt.
Da bin ich zu fest Ökonom.
Ich kann das investierte Kapital
hier nicht so herauswirtschaften,
wie ich es gerne hätte.
Das Futter für die Tiere
will er selber herstellen.
Dazu hat er 240 ha Land -
über 300 Fussballfelder.
Es ist sicherlich
eine andere Perspektive.
Die Flächen sind vorhanden.
Es ist auch eine andere
Cashflow-Marge auf der Milch.
Man hat
ganz andere Kostenstrukturen.
Aber beim Preis,
den man am Ende des Tages zahlt,
ist ganz klar, dass man nicht mehr
in seinem angestammten Zuhause ist.
Mit dem Bauernbetrieb in Frankreich
erhoffen sich die Wiesers
mehr unternehmerische Freiheiten.
Dafür sind sie bereit, die Heimat
und ihr vertrautes Umfeld aufzugeben.
Darf ich schon essen?
- Nein, du musst warten.
Guten Appetit.
Und das bedeutet auch,
Freunde und einen Teil der Familie
zurückzulassen.
* Verspielte Akkordeonklänge *
Zell im Kanton Zürich.
Seit einem knappen Jahr
sind Eva und Philippe hier zu Hause.
So, jetzt brauche ich noch ein Glas.
Zur Einstimmung auf die Toskana
nehmen wir einen Rosso Toscano.
Genau der gehört dazu.
Die beiden sind erst
seit zweieinhalb Jahren ein Paar.
Das hält sie jedoch nicht davon ab,
zusammen ihr grosses Projekt
Agriturismo anzugehen.
Ein Abenteuer.
Ja.
Oder? Sollen wir das so sagen?
Das hat auch
mit dem Bewusstsein zu tun,
dass wir natürlich nicht mehr
40, 50 Jahre vor uns haben.
Das ist eine Tatsache.
Es ist auch nichts Beunruhigendes
oder was auch immer.
Wenn wir noch
etwas miteinander machen wollen,
dann müssen wir es jetzt machen.
Wir haben nicht
noch zehn Jahre Zeit ...
... zum Überlegen.
- ... um zu überlegen, was.
Und klar: no risk no fun.
* Er lacht. *
Ich mache mir eigentlich
nie Gedanken,
dass etwas nicht fertig werden
oder nicht werden könnte.
Ich denke immer, es geht.
Es liegt an mir,
ob es etwas wird oder nicht.
Vielleicht ist es auch anmassend.
Ab und zu bekomme ich auch
eines auf den Deckel.
Aber das schaue ich dann
nicht nur als etwas Negatives an.
Sondern: "Aha,
das ist nicht der richtige Weg."
Also muss ich einen anderen suchen.
Ich habe den Boden schon geputzt.
- Ja, ich weiss.
Das ist ...
- ... Sisyphus.
Unser Hund verliert wieder Haare,
das ist eine Katastrophe.
Ja, das ist schon ...
So.
Wir haben uns über das Internet
kennengelernt.
Lustigerweise ...
Wir hatten ein, zwei Mal
miteinander geredet
und dann eine relativ lange Zeit
nicht mehr.
Mhm.
Dann ging ich das ganze Ding
noch einmal durch und dachte:
Ihre Bezeichnung ...
Du kannst sagen,
wie du dich bezeichnetest.
Allegorie.
- Allegorie.
Da dachte ich,
dass das niemand Normales sein kann,
wenn man so einen Nickname nimmt.
Das ist wirklich etwas Spezielles.
Ja, dann haben wir uns
noch einmal gefunden
und entschieden,
dass wir uns treffen.
Und dann erzählte sie.
Habe ich erzählt? Du aber auch.
- Oh, ja.
Innerhalb von 5 Min. wusste ich,
dass du fünf Häuser umgebaut hast.
Stimmt nicht.
- Oder sieben Häuser umgebaut.
Du hast sieben Kinder
auf die Welt gebracht.
Du hast dieses und jenes
und anderes. Das ging schnell.
So ist das, ganz schnell geht das.
So haben wir uns kennengelernt.
Jetzt können wir das köcheln lassen
für die nächsten paar Stunden.
Joana, nimm zuerst die Kartons.
Lass das bitte stehen.
Ich wollte das nur wegstellen.
Kannst du das bitte schnell
auf die Box stellen?
Bei den Wiesers
heisst es Abschied nehmen.
Tochter Joana zieht aus.
Joana möchte nicht
nach Frankreich mitkommen.
Sie zieht mit ihrem Freund zusammen
und beginnt im Sommer ein Studium.
Jetzt haben sie
eine schöne Wohnung gefunden
und ziehen dieses Wochenende ein.
Ja.
Auch der 26-jährige Sohn Sascha
bleibt hier.
Er hat eine feste Stelle als Maurer.
Ich habe hier
den ganzen Freundeskreis
und auch noch meinen Bruder.
Auch die Sprache ist ein Aspekt.
Ich will die Berufsmatur
und eine Ausbildung machen.
Deshalb bleibe ich in der Schweiz
und probiere es alleine.
Im grössten Notfall kann ich immer
noch zu meinen Eltern zurückgehen.
Das weiss ich, das sagten sie mir.
Nicht stossen, sonst falle ich
rückwärts die Treppe runter.
Warum nehmt ihr es nicht flach?
- Das habe ich auch gedacht.
So ist es einfacher.
- Achtung oben, Joana.
Die 19-jährige Joana trennen bald
1'000 km von ihren Eltern.
Die zwei sind solche ...
Es ist schon speziell,
aber sie macht schon ihren Weg.
Dann nervt sie mich nicht mehr.
- Hat sie dich genervt?
Ja.
- Ach was.
Dann hast du niemand mehr
zum Streiten und Kämpfen.- Ja.
Nein, nein!
* Er giggelt. *
* Schwermütige Klänge *
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
Komm Barney, komm!
Komm Barney, komm. Barney ...
... komm.
Komm, Barney.
Beim Business anstehen, einchecken,
das Gepäck abgeben,
den Kleber dort deponieren,
dann können wir mit Djuna gehen.
Perfekt.
Wir bleiben hier?
- Ja, könntet ihr schnell warten?
Du musst mich nicht einchecken,
ich komme nicht mit.
Endlich geht es los.
In 2 Std. sitzen Marina und Mike
im Flugzeug nach Florida.
Ich bin nervöser als der Hund.
Aber auch nur wegen dem Hund.
Gell, Djuni.
Eine leichte Anspannung ist da.
V.a., bis das Gepäck
am richtigen Ort ist.
Aber sonst ...
Ich habe jetzt 100%ige Vorfreude.
Jetzt geht's endlich los.
Von daher geht das tipptopp.
13.30 Uhr Tampa.
Wir haben noch keine Tickets
wegen dem Upgrade.
Für den Hund noch zahlen.- Den Hund
müssen wir hier noch zahlen.
Hier wäre sie.
- Ein schöner Hund.
Komm, Djuna, komm.
Hündin Djuna muss in den Frachtraum.
Gehen wir.
- Das ist dran.
* Marina lacht. *
Gell, Schatz, das ist dir zu viel.
Wir hätten beide Platz.
Ich könnte bei dir bleiben.
Sie ist ganz ruhig.
Vielen Dank.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Der Flug
geht einmal quer über den Atlantik.
Gut 10 Std. sind sie unterwegs.
Geht's?
- Ja.
Kommt schon gut.
Man kann
keine schöne Ferien wünschen ...
Rund 8'000 km
sind es bis Tampa in Florida.
Hab dich lieb.
- Ich dich auch.
Pass auf dich auf.
- Du auch.
Ihr meldet euch, gell?
Ja, sobald wir dort sind,
rufen wir euch an.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Am Morgen um 0.30 Uhr
hört ihr von uns.- Ist gut.
Mike, mach's gut.
Danke für alles.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
* Einfühlsame Klänge *
* Grillen zirpen. *
Es sind nur ein paar Stunden
mit dem Auto,
doch in der Toskana wähnt man sich
fast in einer anderen Welt.
Philippe hat sich
eine Woche Zeit genommen.
Er möchte letzte Dinge
für die Auswanderung vorbereiten.
Über ein halbes Jahr
war er nicht mehr hier.
Hier sind wir so oft gefahren,
als wir die Häuser gesucht haben.
Es ist irgendwie wie Heimkommen.
Ein Anwesen auf dem Land -
gut 20 km von der nächstgrösseren
Stadt Follonica entfernt -
soll Philippes und Evas
neues Zuhause werden.
Freude und viele Erwartungen.
Erwartungen an ein Abenteuer.
An etwas, das ich mit meinen Händen
erschaffen kann.
Also, das ist unser Zuhause.
Mit den Häusern.
Hallo.
Buongiorno, Roberto. Come sta?
Bene.
Philippe hat einen Termin
mit dem Verkäufer der Liegenschaft.
Bauunternehmer Roberto hat die Häuser
erst vor Kurzem fertiggestellt.
Maklerin Martina,
eine ausgewanderte Schweizerin,
vermittelte die Immobilie.
Stiamo guardando un po'.
- Facciamo il tour.
Bellissimo.
Ein Wohnhaus ...
... sechs Ferienwohnungen ...
... und ein Pool.
Dazu 18 ha Land, auf denen sie
Olivenbäume pflanzen wollen.
Bisher haben die Schweizer
nur einen Vorvertrag unterzeichnet.
Der definitive Kauf steht noch aus.
Schon ein wenig anders
als das letzte Mal.- Ja.
Die Klimaanlage ist auch schon drin.
Das ist wirklich ...
Das wird unser Wohnhaus sein.
Und zwar ...
Es ist noch nicht alles vollständig.
Das dort hinten in der Ecke
wird der Bereich sein,
wo später ein Cheminée hinkommt.
Das wird eine schöne,
gemütliche Ecke.
Und die Küche?
Da haben sie jetzt alles ausgeräumt?
Wir haben gemeinsam
mit Eva und dem Küchenbauer
das letzte Mal lange überlegt.
Aber ich denke, es kommt gut.
Wobei, was ich definitiv nicht will,
ist, dass der Ofen
nicht auf Arbeitshöhe ist.
Oh, okay.
- Das will ich haben.
Erstens bin ich meistens der,
der ihn braucht,
und zweitens
werden wir nicht jünger.
Das Bücken ist für dich das Problem.
Dann so die Lasagne rausholen
finde ich nicht gut.
Wir haben uns lange
darüber unterhalten.
Habt ihr das
mit dem Küchenbauer geregelt?
Ich glaube, sie hat es bestellt.
Hat sie?
- Ja, ich glaube.
Ja, schön. Gut, weiss man das.
Ich glaube, das ist so.
- Ich muss sie fragen.
* Freizeichen *
Grüezi, Herr Farmer.
- Grüezi,Frau Agrobesitzerin.
* Eva lacht. *
Okay.
Ich habe mit Schrecken
von Martina vernommen,
dass du das Zeug für die Küche,
so wie er es vorgeschlagen hat,
bereits bestellt hast.
Was habe ich bestellt?
- Für unsere Küche.
Ja?
- Die hast du bestellt?
Ja.
- Ja, ist gut, also.
Er sagte,
das würde sechs Wochen dauern.
Aber das ist nicht genau
unsere Abmachung.
Wir können es ja noch anpassen,
das ist doch kein Problem.
Warum?- Es gibt immer
für alles eine Lösung.
Du musst einfach ein Element
auswechseln, nichts Kompliziertes.
Nein, das ist nicht ganz so, wenn
man den Ofen auf Arbeitshöhe möchte,
dann muss man das anders machen.
Ach.
Das müssen wir nochmals anschauen.
Ja, okay.
- Okay, also.
Tschüssi, tschau.
- Tschüss. Tschau, tschau
Ich habe ihr von Anfang an gesagt,
dass mir das nicht passt.
Es ist wahrscheinlich ...
... schon angebracht,
dass wir das noch klären.
Good morning.
I take the youngest ones.
Yes.
With my car. All rein.
- All together?
And then directly, it's easier.
4.30 Uhr in der Früh im Aargau.
Bauer Sandro
und seine Frau Aleksandra
bereiten die Kälber für den Transport
nach Frankreich vor.
Ein historischer Moment:
Die letzte Schweizer Ohrmarke,
die ich reindrücken muss.
Voila!
- Achtung.
Den Umzug macht Familie Wieser
in Etappen.
Zuerst bringen sie die Tiere
nach Frankreich.
Möbel und Hausrat
folgen zwei Wochen später.
Es wird einem schon bewusst.
Ja, man geht.
So.
- Kommt.
* Sie pfeifen. *
Braves Mädchen, komm.
Heute nehmen sie nur Kälber
und Rinder mit.
Die Milchkühe
kommen in den nächsten Transport.
Komm Mädel, komm.
Also, dann machen wir das noch mal.
Komm, schau mal hier.
Schau mal da, Schatzi.
* Drollige Klänge *
Nimm sie doch!
- Hey!
Nimm doch den Strick.
- Er hat keinen Knoten mehr drin.
Dann machst du einen.
- Halte sie doch einfach vorne!
* Er keucht. *
Komm.
Allez!
* Sie pfeift. *
Zehn, elf, zwölf.
14 Std. Fahrt sind es bis ans Ziel.
Einmal quer durch Frankreich.
* Er pfeift. *
Alles gut, Mädchen.
Und so geht es weiter.
Tschüss. Melde dich
und fahr vorsichtig.- Adieu.
Bauer Sandro begleitet seine Tiere
auf den neuen Hof.
Jeder kürzeste Transport ist immer
ein gewisses Risiko für die Tiere.
Ich hoffe natürlich schon,
dass es gut geht.
In der Schule muss Sohn Gian
seinen Freunden Adieu sagen.
(Junge) Lieber Gian, das ist
ein Andenken für dich von uns allen.
Danke.
Im neuen Heim in Florida werden für
Mike und Marina erste Träume wahr.
In gewissen Sachen
leben wir den American Dream.
Ihr zukünftiges Waffelrestaurant
in einer Shopping Mall
nimmt langsam Formen an.
Mein Herz schlägt schneller,
je näher es kommt.
Und in der Toskana lässt Philippe
bereits 800 Olivenbäume pflanzen.
Doch dann fangen die Probleme an:
Der Besitzer der Liegenschaft
möchte den Vertrag ändern.
Der Verkauf droht zu platzen.
Auf keinen Fall unterschreiben.
# U si stiige in Flüüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chömme nümme hei.
# U si löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neues Dihei.
# Si göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Michaela Hoss - 2022